- [Sighing]
Wish y'all would have told me.
I would have got dressed up again.
- [Taylor Rooks:] This isn’t dressed up?
- Nah, I wore a bulletproof vest.
You know, I was trying to make a
statement before you got here.
[Phone beeping]
- [Taylor:] Did you really
wear a bulletproof vest?
Can you show me the vest?
- Oh.
It has pretty much every
possible name of someone
who's died from police
brutality, police violence.
On the back too.
Doesn't matter how much
money or how famous you
are, like, as an
African American male, that's
who we are.
You know, it doesn't matter
what your job,
what your name is, and
I think being able to
wear the bulletproof vest just shows that
I kinda have my hands up as well.
Just kinda like, look, hands up,
don't shoot, you know.
We're tired of seeing this.
We're tired. We're tired.
And everybody's tired of it.
So for me to make that
statement, I think it was
just something that I
really wanted to do and
I think as African Americans,
male or female, we're
sick and tired of being afraid, you know.
I think that's something
I really want to speak on.
- [Orlando Airport Overhead Announcement:] Welcome to Orlando. The local time is 10:33.
- [Announcer:] Tonight's
presentation of the
national anthem has
been recorded and sung by
a transformational youth organization
in the African American
community.
- Well we knew we were
gonna be the first game
and we would have an
opportunity to make a statement.
- The biggest thing was just
finding something we could all do
together. And I brought it to them,
and I was like, “Look,
this is what we wanna do.”
And, you know, credit to
everybody that was a part of it.
We appreciate the support.
- It’s a first, and I'm proud
to be part of this league.
- Every day that I'm here,
I get the opportunity to
hear players talk about things they care
deeply about.
The changes they want to see in the world.
They are so passionate
about so many things.
It's not just basketball.
It's really amazing to
be a part of.
[Drums, instrumental]
I love empty buses.
It's a very weird thing,
but I love when I'm the
only person inside of a
huge vehicle.
I just wanna scream.
Next up, Houston Rockets
taking on the
Memphis Grizzlies.
This will be my first time ever watching
the Grizzlies in person.
I'm excited to watch
Ja Morant.
- [Announcer:] Game time.
- [Offscreen:] Where are you?
- Ah, I'm in a bubble
- [Taylor laughing]
- Hi, Danny!
- Hi, how are you?
- Hurry up, LeBron. Whenever you're ready.
- [LeBron James:] I gotta get
some food and some wine.
[Laughing]
- [Taylor:] All right, Bron is about be DJ.
[Big K.R.I.T.’s “2000 & Beyond” playing]
OK, let's make sure we are framed up.
- I think that's why it was
important for us to play
cuz I think at the end of the day,
you know, how now everything is
so based about social media.
So something could be the trend
or, you know, quote, unquote,
or the wave, like the Black
Lives Matter movement,
and then three, four months later,
it just starts to
die down.
And for us, you know, it's
not gonna hit that three or four
months and then die down because
we're kinda picking it
back up, and we continue to raise awareness.
[Intense violin]
- Really been so much
unity and conversation
between players.
And so now that players
are using their voices,
it's just about making
sure people are listening
and still tuning in.
- [Offscreen:] Thank you, Russell.
- All right, thank you. Appreciate it.
- [Taylor: ] Are those
gonna be for sale?
- [Russell:] No.
- [Taylor:] Wow, that's crazy. OK.
- [Russell:] But if you want one, I’ll
get you one.
- [Taylor:] I would love one. I'd love one.
- [Russell:] Which one do you
want, it to say on the back?
They've got like 10 different ones.
So you just let me know, and I'll get you one.
- [Taylor:] No, I'd love
one. Thank you so much.
- [Russell:] I'll bring it Sunday.
- [Taylor] OK, for
sure. I appreciate you.
- [Russell:] Yep, no problem.
- [Taylor:] Thank you, Russ.
[Serious music]
- All Black people unjustly killed, many
by the hands of police.
I chose the back that
says "Power to the people."
- [Taylor:] Hey, Doc.
So, I see your hat
saying “Vote.”
- Yeah.
- You guys have a lot of different symbolism
and signage on the
on the coaches’ shoes, hats and
everything like that.
So what have you kind of
learned about yourself
as a coach during this
time? And what is important
for you to do for your guys
and for your assistant coaches?
- Well, for me as a coach,
I've learned two things:
No. 1, I've always
been extremely political
but not enough.
You know. You know, we had
a great speaker recently
talk to our team. And, you know, one of the—
he said, I don't know how anyone
can say they're not involved in politics
because politics are
involved your daily lives,
whether you want it or not.
Decisions are being made whether you're
involved or not.
So why wouldn't you be
involved? That's the
first thing.
And the second thing, I hate to say it—
I think I'm getting
old, and I think I should listen
to the young people. You know,
I think this movement is
really driven by the young.
And so my job is to
inspire them to vote and
get involved and then
back up and let them do
the talking and us do the listening.
I think that's very
important in this movement
And if we can do that, then
we don't just have young
people involved in politics
now but we have people
involved in politics for life.
And I think that's very important for us.
- Game 1. It has arrived.
The NBA has returned.
We're tipping off with the
Jazz taking on the Pelicans.
Zion Williamson is playing.
He's back on campus.
I can't wait. I have waited
for this day. Let's do it.
[Squeaking shoes and whistle blowing]
[Upbeat music]
[Basketball bouncing]
- [Taylor:] We can't touch it. I'm sorry.
[Upbeat music]
[Laughing]
- I truly believe that
us as athletes have a
huge platform. Because us as people
have platforms that we
all can use to be able to give back
to our community,
to be able to educate
our people. And that's
something I believe
in, something I've been
doing since Day 1.
And I'll continue to do it
to be able to bridge and close
that gap.
And that's just how I feel.
- I don't think that, you know,
kneeling or putting on a
T-shirt for me personally is the answer.
I feel like, for me, Black
lives are supported through
the gospel.
All lives are supported
through the gospel. That we
all,
like I said, have
things that we do wrong
and sometimes it gets
to a place of pointing
fingers about which wrong is worse.
And whose wrong is seen, so
I feel like the Bible tells us that
we all fall short of
God's glory. And that at the end of the day
whoever will humble themselves
and seek God and repent their sins,
that we could see
it in a different light.
- I'm happy I'm getting you
with the pick in your hair.
It looks nice.
- You don't see what's
on the pick, do you?
Because it's backwards.
- [Offscreen:] What is it?
- Oh, there we go. It
is power to the people.
Do you see the pick?
Where'd you get that?
- I don't know. Amazon. Six dollars.
- A steal.
- Yeah, definitely.
It's an amazing feeling
to see how far we've
come and we still have so
much more to go, you know?
But it's an amazing feeling to see that we are
taking steps in a positive direction.
We just gotta remember
that it's not finished.
The job isn't done yet.
We just gotta continue
to do what we can to
use our platform to let
everyone know that this
is something that's not
temporary, you know?
This is something that
we will continue to do
until we are answered.
- [Taylor:] What is it that you would like to see
from the owners that
would make you feel like
they get it?
- Just some acknowledgement.
I think that's a huge part
of taking some ownership.
That, you know, half our league, I mean,
80 percent of our league
is African American men.
And they need to make sure
that they voice that to us
show their concerns show
that they're supporting
the things we want to do
for our communities, for our people.
Especially now more than ever.
It's something that I think
is very, very important.
especially you know owners
should take knowledge
of that.
- [Taylor:] Finish this sentence for me.
Black people are:
- Probably just "beautiful."
I think, you know, obviously, that
goes much more into,
much more in depth than just the physical.
You know, mentally, I think
we're a brilliant race,
who's smart, you know,
who don't get
its just due. You know, obviously, but.
We're a race who's just beautiful.
- [Taylor:] So, Chris, I know
you guys want awareness
and you want change. But
once this Orlando campus
has finished, what will have to have happened
for you to say, "We were successful in that"?
- That's a great question.
That's a great question.
I think the more we all
continue to get educated,
you know, what I mean?
And coming down here, what
we have the opportunity to do
is use our collective
voices, obviously to spread
the message, but we also
get a chance to educate
each other. With whatever it may be.
Whether it's financial
literacy. Whether it is
police reform. Whether it is
education. Whether it's
HBCUs.
Guys can start to build together.
That's what we've been
talking about. We need to,
we need to unite,
become a united force
in a lot of this action that's going on, so.
I'm not the one to
determine this, but it's just
things that I like to see.
- [Donovan Mitchell:] The
game was great. We won by two.
But at the end of the day,
Breonna Taylor's killers
are still free.
There are so many different
things that we can honestly
talk about.
I'm gonna continue to
talk about Breonna Taylor.
That's near and dear to me.
I'm gonna keep it on the
forefront of people's minds.
You know, and I think they wanted to
do something as well and
just being able to bring
that to them and being able
to do it, just showed
how collectively as a group
and as a league we're going to
continue to keep that
on everybody's minds.
- [Taylor:] LeBron, you
talked about what you want
next for Breonna Taylor
in terms of justice.
But what do you want
next in terms of us, in
terms of Americans?
What does an improved
America look like to you?
- I mean, that's a great question.
And it's something that I
rationalize and think about
every single day.
You know, what's next?
What can I do next to
make an impact in our
communities?
You know, not only for my people, but also
for America in general.
You know obviously
justice for Breonna Taylor
is No. 1 on all
of our lists right now
because we just, we know the story, we know
how…it's just crazy what went
on with that situation
and how horrific it is.
So, but for us as America,
to get better? That's
a question we kinda tinker with every day.
And it's something I play
with in my mind every day
and listen to the people
around me and also listen
to my family and things of that nature.
But, you know, the
conversation, people sometimes
are just afraid to have a conversation.
And I think one of the
best things in life is
communication.
- Power to the people. Black lives matter.
[Scribbling]